So the question is how do we find the time.
Actually, sorry that's not the question. Finding the time is easy--we'll just look at the sun.
The real question is how I can keep the time from my local harbor when I go to sail at sea.
What I need is periodicity. I need something that happens at regular intervals.
For example, we're all familiar with the ticking of a clock and that seems like an obvious solution
but clocks are difficult to make--what else could we use that has a regular periodic nature to it.
One attempted solution to this problem of finding something periodic that we could use
as a timekeeper came from our good friend Galileo--
standing as he always does next to the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
Now Galileo had invented some incredible telescopes and with these telescopes,
he was able to observe the ring around the planet Saturn, mountains on the moon,
dark spots on the sun and the planet Jupiter and its four moons,
each of which orbited around in a predictable fashion.
Now of the four discoveries Galileo made with his telescope, which do you think
could somehow be used for keeping time at sea.